acer aujourd'hui m'a regardé devrait
parler comme s'il existait je crois
qu'ils entrent qui commence à changer
je suis deuxième camp mais comme maman
comme les autres c est l'éthique on n'a
pas le gel mais comme dopant n'est pas
comme elle
les médicaments sa protection donc tu
fais savoir une vie normale dehors pas
cher payé pour ta libertaire vas-y
liberté juifs de rien du tout j'ai
jamais loin de faire ce que je
rencontrais balados te plaît que je fais
c'est pour te protéger
qu'est ce que tu es et moi
[Musique]
sa fille meredith reed tu voulais tu
pourras y là
[Musique]
tu vas me l'a amenée ici
saison c'est moi qui hier et la chercher
[Musique]
c'est phil c'est une grenade dégoupillée